you're still in that rental house huh
you're still not in that new house you
bought dude i told you we were gonna be
here till the end of october what don't
you get about that
that was the whole end of october
i just yeah i thought you were working
now you said october i said we have this
place for three [ __ ] months and we're
here till the end of october what else
what don't you understand about that the
guy said to me ronnie uh is waiting for
his furniture i go oh ronnie bought new
furniture you know because i you know
with covid things have been slowed down
they go no he's waiting for his own
furniture i said what is it what are
they are they delivering that covered
wagon or something
before you did
yeah
like months ago it went into [ __ ]
storage okay
where did you store it in queens
yeah no it's it's stored in new york yes
what's your story why didn't you ship it
down to uh vegas and store it there
because it's ridiculous to do that
because you have to hire two moving
companies what's good for that so why
not do it the other way
drive it to vegas before you got here
put it in storage and then have a moving
company to put it into in vegas
what's the difference to do that what
the [ __ ] you still got to pay twice no
because you have to give them notice
it's going it's going cross-country it's
not like you're moving [ __ ] ten
blocks
all i know is you notice
i said let's put a tracker on this
bucket of furniture see how long it
takes to follow it across the country
someone said yeah
they're going to find brian laundry
before they find ronnie's furniture yeah
good for jt
that's a good line then he goes i go
yeah we got to find ronnie's furniture
they go yeah get dog the bounty hunter
on it
everybody's so [ __ ] smart why are you
so angry this morning man you know what
i know what happened he went out i know
what happened i know it happened it went
out later
he was crying out last night yeah did
you go out last night no it did not go
out [ __ ]
you went out monday night not tonight
last night
i didn't drink it all monday no wonder
you were home so fast sorry it bothers
you robin
nothing bothers me yeah everything
bothers you
peter's making them cranky how hot is it
there it's gorgeous
70 last night yeah my balls look like
charcoal briquettes now [ __ ] you too
[ __ ] jealous bastards
i'll be laughing when you're sitting in
10 feet of snow yeah i'm just cranky
because stephanie couldn't find the lube
last night i had to go rough with the
dildo no we have no problem with that
dude wow